hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
I'm taking a look at the top 5 tech
myths and when I say top I kind of mean
the top 5 that are sort of floating
around right now some of these you may
already know are myth some of them you
might actually be a victim of thinking
or true the first of these has to do
with cameras the myth is the more
megapixels the better and this is
sometimes true in some very limited
cases but I mean honestly this isn't
actually the complete picture this would
be true if the only thing that
differentiated cameras was the number of
megapixels or sensors were capable of
capturing but it's actually not a good
camera is made by overall good optics so
a good lens fast lens good glass an
overall wide aperture all sorts of
different things make up a good lens and
the sensor that's behind them all and
another myth that kind of falls
underneath that is that an 8 megapixel
photo is twice as tall and twice as wide
as a four megapixel photo not exactly
true and aim a pixel image resolution
has twice as many total pixels as a four
megapixel photo resolution but as you
can see it doesn't double the vertical
and horizontal resolution it just totals
8 million pixels and totals 4 million
pixels so you don't have to worry about
having a drastically larger image when
going from 18 to 22 ma pixels it's
really not a whole giant ik noticeable
difference if number two is that insert
tweak here will automatically
drastically speed up the speed of your
computer so obviously a lot of the
tech-savvy people already know that
these myths are for the most part
completely untrue and these are kind of
like the worst myths out there because
they spread more frequently than the
other types of myths everyone's always
looking for a quick free effortless
painless way to like drastically speed
up your computer but honestly Android
cast killers are a perfectly
controversial example cast killers on
Android were originally meant to free up
RAM and then in turn save battery life
because it's killing processes that
would be using CPU cycles and RAM but
that turned out to be a bit of a placebo
effect because Android itself is
actually very good at managing memory
honestly there is no magical thing you
can do to drastically speed up your
computer or phone or tablet but the most
common secret that people don't actually
know is this maintenance just actually
taking care of what you do on your
device and actually
what you're installing and how it
affects what you're actually doing so
just know what you're doing with your
device and you'll be fine
myth number three is that max can't get
viruses what not even scratch the
surface on this one but yes max can get
viruses every computer user whether or
not they have an anti-virus installed
whether or not they're on Mac os10 Linux
Windows or any other operating system
needs to be careful about what they
click and needs to be careful about what
they download and install there is some
truth to the fact that there are more
viruses out there for Windows machines
than there are for Mac machines for
example I mean think about it from the
perspective of a malicious hacker if
you're going to write a virus for
example who are you gonna write it for
Windows because Windows is on 92% of the
active computers out there on the
Internet today
but yes max can get viruses be careful
next myth is that if you don't safely
eject that USB Drive your computer will
freak out and just explode the idea
behind this is that you actually want to
avoid unplugging your USB drives when
it's in the process of actually writing
or reading data so if it's actually
doing something and you unplug it while
it's doing that thing you might corrupt
the file that it was writing so if you
drag a picture from the USB Drive to
your computer and suddenly unplug it
while it's transferring the picture you
pretty much just lost that picture but
if it's idle like you're not reading or
writing anything to it you can just
unplug it like it's I know it's going to
give you the error but you have the
ability to turn that error message off
and you can just unplug it's very safe I
actually watched someone during a
PowerPoint presentation finish his
presentation the teacher went to unplug
the USB flash drive and he said no no no
no stop stop stop I need to safely eject
this hardware
the fifth and final myth kind of rhymed
is that Internet Explorer sucks
well okay well you see I've been a bit
of a culprit for this one I do know that
Internet Explorer is a much better
browser than it used to be the latest
version of it is anyway it's more of a
coding nightmare in the background but
you know while Internet Explorer isn't
quite as good as Chrome or Firefox or
opera that doesn't mean it sucks it's
just not quite as good as the other
browsers but it's alright if you use it
I'm not gonna freak out on you I'm just
gonna say check out Google Chrome Oh
looks like we have a new myth here it
says the myth is that beats by dre suck
that's not a myth now either way thanks
for watching this video guys if you
enjoyed it feel free to like it and if
you haven't already subscribed to this
YouTube channel I might be pointing yeah
if you haven't already subscribed to
this YouTube channel you can do that I
do post videos a lot more often now that
it is summertime so either way thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you guys
in the next one
[Music]
you